well I think theoretically well there's
two there's two schools of thought one
is that nothing that the brain has ever
carved into its patterns ever goes away
but and that's a necessity because the
patterns you learn of course are
networked with other patterns and so you
know if when somebody promises you they
can eliminate a pattern let's say they
can eliminate your fear of flying
pattern well that fear of flying pattern
is networked with a whole bunch of other
stuff if that would really disappear
then all other kind of stuff would
disappear and so you know suddenly you
find yourself you can no longer Drive
while you're driving right or something
like that so the brain makes it so that
everything that has ever been learned is
there forever however how active a
neural pathway is is a completely
different story so you can create an
alternate pathway so to speak so that
the information and the electrical
impulse goes down a different road and
this road becomes so to speak overgrown
and no longer used so that's very
possible but of course one of those
things with those overgrown no longer
used roads is that they were in a prime
that there were earliest roads so
they're the best networked so it's
highly unlikely that you're never going
to end up on that roads right so because
you would have to rewire everything but
technically speaking it is possible to
block access to a road so to speak and
create a much stronger road somewhere
else and like for instance one classic
example for that is language right so I
grew up speaking Austrian and so
everything up to when I left Europe
because I lived in Austria and I lived
in Germany so I spoke German till I was
26
right and then I spoke only English
other than once a week with my parents
or so so my English is now my
primary language a dream in English even
count in English which was the longest I
used to count in in German long after
everything else had gone - and math
right but but now everything's English
and I can write a lot better in English
than I can in German believe it or not
but because I haven't written in German
in 20-something years so so my Austrian
patterns are not really that accessed
but the moment I speak Austrian
everything that comes with that
including the cultural behaviors the
mannerisms the way my body holds itself
comes back and it's hilarious because I
go home and I spend the week with my
parents and I can tell my body shifts
right and it's not entirely Pleasant at
times but because that part of me hasn't
been used and isn't really yes a little
bit like that yeah exactly
yeah something like that so so that
gives you not really but now
but but yes so you know meaning meaning
that's a classic example of can you get
rid of those attachment points and stuff
like that yes you can but when they come
back they'll come back online really
quickly so for instance you know
sometimes people go on ayahuasca
journeys and stuff like that and they
report that when they have done that
there's other ways to do it too in
somatic release for instance that stuff
is just gone
like smoking right or certain painful
physical conditions or memories or stuff
like that
the capacity to earn a living
the sudden urge to disclose one steepest
psyche on Facebook right after and I ask
a true all of those things but I mean
I'm you know that you can't somatically
release things and they're gone
and and I certainly can say that that's
true even within my own body that I've
just released certain things but the
patterning in the mind it might not be
stored in my body anymore but I can
still access it and so it's both orders
repetition and building new patterns and
finding the right access to release
there's all kinds of modalities amongst
them cognitive behavioral therapy right
there's all and and can work on triggers
you can I mean there's all kinds of
things you can do to give yourself
enough space that when the trigger hits
you are not just running down that road
but of course as long as you and this is
the problem with cognitive therapies and
I'm saying this having been you know a
counsellor for many years and having
done extensive academic work around this
as well there's only so much talking and
knowing can do for you because the the
body pattern is
so strong but it overrides for the most
part your knowledge the best you can
hope for is that you get enough space
that you can put your body in a
different position so to speak right or
you create a state break that makes it
you don't go down that road but if you
actually work on releasing things from
your body that's a much I don't know
much more effective route